[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club ten of Africa's
greatest chess players compete in
Abidjan as Vivendi presents the 2018
cote d'ivoire
rapid and glitz Invitational hello chess
fans Ben Simon and grandmaster Robert
Hahn gaskey here for the final day of
action for the 2018 cote d'ivoire rapid
and blitz and we have a champion
straight away in blitz round 12
it was clinched mathematically although
we knew beforehand that grandmaster dr.
bossom amin would be the champion of
this event Robert yeah that was a pretty
much what we were expecting going out of
day one of the blitzing going into day
two but it is on an IV John for second
place though it is all in an abbey John
it is yeah so there is a pretty I would
say intense dispute between Kenny
Solomon well before we okay before we
get to that we'll get to the standings
just like Solomon and hadoo SH are
battling it out for a second place well
get around to this okay all right let's
take a look at the game that I while
we're doing well which game what's gonna
do I look at I thought you said we were
gonna get to a game oh we have a lot of
games oh well then we can hold on hold
on on what now I'm confused okay so this
is what we're gonna do I got some
bloopers for you okay like those but
also we have even though Amin won the
tournament he also lost his first game
in the event so that's kind of exciting
and no no there then he lost his first
game after he clinched it right yeah
yeah so after after around 12
he lost blitz 13 yeah yeah - Kenny so so
he clinched it in round 12 and then he
looks oh so it usually happens you know
when you accomplish something in aterna
like when you get a norm or you like
clinched the
then you sort of let your guard down
right and that's when people start you
know thinking okay this is my chance
well he's got the grand prize now he
does have he's got the five grand in his
pocket and I'm guessing he's still
concerned you know he doesn't want to
lose rating or anything so he's still
motivated to score as many points as
possible right so there are games going
on right now at chess 24 calm
well actually this round has just ended
but the game the tournament is in
progress on chess 24 comm check it out
see IV rapid in blitz and follow the
games along with us we'll be covering
one game per round mostly until they end
if we have them I'd like to take a look
at the field of the players and we were
talking about the the gap between bossom
Amin and the rest of the field 2681
Universal rating for a mean and really
it's been a great predictor of his
performance in this event but you were
looking at the feed a ratings earlier
and you made an interesting assessment
tell us about that well it was funny
because Amin has scored a very
impressive amount of points I think it's
something like 26 and a half 27 and a
half right now out of 33 out of 32
yeah 34 34 okay so it's a it's an
impressive percentage but still I mean
up until he won his most recent round he
was losing rating which seems kind of
insane to me because so his feed a
ratings were actually going down yeah
yeah going into this I think it's like
the third round before last he was
losing one rating point which is
mind-boggling to me I mean how many
points do you need to score their gain
rating it's just because he's just so
much higher rated than the rest it is it
is but it just goes to show you that's
kind of you know a very heavy pressure
that that rating puts on you because it
demands that you score just an absurd
amount of points right so of course
we're not talking about feed a classical
ratings that would be affected but
rather wrap it in blitz because the
format of this event is rapid and blitz
and this being the final day or
concentrating exclusively on blitz
it meets game in five minutes with a
three-second delay we've already seen
one round-robin yesterday we have two
rounds left to complete the entire
tournament each game is worth one point
and a draw will net you a half point and
as well if we have standings current
standings I'd like to see them okay so
we have these these games have been
coming in really rapidly and so these
standings are after blitz round 16
remember there are 18 rounds and okay
well we know who the champion is and we
most likely know who's second place is
going to be as well Robert yeah it seems
like in the last couple of rounds
Muhammad fiducia has been able to sort
of slip away from the pack with second
place so battle for third anyone know I
mean you do have a battle for third
between L at Nani and Solomon but I
think well mathematically that's it
second place is for Muhammad kaduche as
well right we got two rounds to go and
he's got two and a half point lead yeah
no yeah I guess that's I don't want to
risk playing the fool
but if my math serves me well that is
just way too many points yeah you're
absolutely right before the last round
was the last time I looked at the
standings and well there was a slight
possibility but no longer yes Muhammad
huh do she has clinched second place in
this event but so if Solomon wants to
secure third place he's actually got a
pretty spicy game coming up because he's
playing a douche oh that's got to be the
game we have to watch yeah rather over
17 so maybe he'll try to play the
spoiler role not to spoil it but he'll
play for bragging rights saying okay you
got a douche got second place but I'd
beat him right yeah well and not only
are they playing for bragging rights but
also trying to clinch that third place
prize we do have money on the line here
Robert so it's I know I know by now that
first place is 5 grand but about second
and third I kind of forget about those
you're in luck it's still like a nice
chunk of change it is
all right so first place is five grand
but then we go down to increments of
$1,000 see it's really easy to remember
Robert this is a nice tournament yeah
4,000 3,000 2,000 1,000 now it would be
a lot easier to remember the prizes if
like first place with a was a thousand
second was two thousand third was the
three thousand I don't want to play in
that tournament no no it doesn't make a
lot of sense but it is easier to
remember interesting thoughts from yeah
I mean you know for the organize like
all around the world
my idea is our open source they can
borrow borrowed lovely alright we have
seven and a half minutes until the start
of our seventeenth blitz round so please
join us at chess twenty four calm but
let's take a look back at an interesting
game that you saw and piqued your
interest Robert yeah absolutely I mean
when you see the top seen losing his
only game of the tournament at least so
far we still have to round this was from
blitz thirteen right the one well the
one right after he clinched it it was
okay so Kenny Solomon versus bossa the
me yes we're waiting for this next round
to start I thought this would be
interesting to look at because Solomon
won a very nice game so we see Bosma
mean sticking to his guns with these
Kings Indian or Kings Indian attack type
of cross structures whether he plays it
with white or black and maybe this was I
would say the mistake but since his pawn
structure has been serving him so well
write with d6
e v g6 was working out for him why
change it now you know it's like in the
NFL when you got a team that's winning
you know you kind of just leave the team
as it is and era think bossman had a
pretty good team with E 5 so switching
up at this point maybe some burying so
on a subconscious level not the best
idea so what happens now is that the
game transitions into a Benoni pawn
structure
and after rook e8 Bishop d3 Bishop h6 a
very tricky move which is going to
require that white sacrificed this pawn
on III after castles takes takes well in
the game bas and play Queen e7 didn't
capture this pawn the problem if you go
rook d2 I mean it takes III I go Queen
d2 and you're gonna have some problems
along the dark squares so when this rook
retreats the Queen's going to come to h6
the Knights gonna come to g5 and already
you're gonna start feeling the pain
along the F file so after F takes III
Queen e7 hoping to take advantage of the
backward pawn if not capturing it right
away at least putting pressure along the
dark squares and after a6 Queen d2 the
problem for black is that white is still
going to be able to play something like
rook F to work a f1 and use this app
file as well as some of the weekend dark
squares on the Kings side and we'll see
Solomon really took advantage of this
now black sacrificed a pawn on the Queen
side hoping to get some Benko style
counter play along the a and B files but
whenever you have to balance themes for
example what's more important bishop
pair or pawn structure what's more
important open files or King safety King
safety should always be number one you
can have a beautiful pawn structure you
have the bishop pair you can have
excellent piece play but if you get
checkmated you still lose the game so
even though White's position I mean
White has an extra pawn in this position
he also has better King safety so I
think this is a terrible position for
black and already he's in big trouble
now after Knight b3 vaasana' means
sacked the exchange hoping that this
would allow him to restore some of that
dark square control by trading off
brooks and using his knights especially
as d7 Knight along the dark squares
heading for the e5 outpost so after
Knight takes d5 Knight b6 90 to 95 there
we go I think this was blacks last hope
that this knight on e5 could make a
for everything else but didn't quite
work out that way because white is
always gonna have an outside passer in
the endgame we also see that King safety
maybe not as serious of an issue as
before but still something to keep in
mind and with the Queen's on the board
white should have more than enough to
win this game and this is pretty much
what happened right white trade at
Knights Queen d5 we also have some
pressure along the backward pawn on d6
maybe a 8 B 3 C 4 takes check King H 1 D
c5 and we'll see that the combined
effect of the outside passer and the
King safety and the presence of Queens
is going to overwhelm blacks position
there's too many fronts to fight on and
not enough pieces to cover all of them
so der King g8 rook e1
with the humble threat of checkmate
Queen a4 shouldn't get ahead of
ourselves because now the Queen is
defending p8 we now 6 threatening to go
rookie 7 now and take the knight so
Queen d7 rook be one Queen c7 look at
you on 27 repetition of moves of course
boy is not interested in drawing this
game and simply by maneuvering around
keeping the Queen's on this is gonna be
a very difficult position for black to
play so now after age six Queens sneaks
into the Kings side again King safety
now the sides of the game after King h7
rook D 1 C 363 p6 sorry black resigned
right can't stop Queen takes 3-6
threatening the Queen you're gonna get
mated game's over a nice win by Kenny
Solomon who's hoping who was hoping at
this point to fight for second place as
we know how to do she has already
clinched it but nevertheless a nice win
well third won't be too shabby for the
man from Venice Italy by way of South
Africa Grandmaster Kenny Solomon and so
how do you he must be feeling good being
the first one to knock off him I mean
yeah I mean that's whenever you beat an
elite player someone that's you know
been over 2700 feet a 2681 urs is that
how we're call
Universal right universal radio urs is
the system an impressive win because it
wasn't just you know the wind that you
see on paper I mean you go over the game
and you can see that he all played him
there was a somewhat of a difference
between the Blitz games of today and the
Blitz games of yesterday the ones
yesterday were blunder 'fl and crazy and
I was a little bit different right yeah
I mean when I was playing through the
games today's games I was thinking of
you know like these boxing matches were
it's like round 14 or something which
doesn't exist anymore but it doesn't no
no man I like boxing like the classical
fights so I don't watch like the more
recent ones so I like watching like
round 14 it's just like the boxers
telling their trainers don't throw in
the towel yet like I got this you know
and everybody's just slugging it out and
it's just a battle against yourself you
know like how how much can you take and
what I am getting from these games is
that the players aren't necessarily
going all-out crazy like they were
yesterday now it's like okay I'm just
gonna bring my pieces out I'm gonna you
know kind of like the little rope-a-dope
type of action and maybe I'll get a
counter-attack in but you can tell that
fatigue is playing a role so the players
just don't have the energy to keep up
that kind of intensity to the games that
we've been seeing so far so it reminded
me kind of like you know that fight the
Thrilla in Manilla between Ali and
Frazier
where you know I leave at least man a
trainer was about to throw in the towel
and you know it was just like you know
who was gonna crack first right I think
that's a little bit of what we're seeing
to take off the gloves take off the
gloves and I Fraser quit right keep the
gloves on yeah you know yeah yeah yeah
that was interesting lore well unlike
Ali not a lot of people can rope-a-dope
successfully so yeah there is a lot of
fatigue going on here in this event do
you have any other I do and speaking of
the rope-a-dope
well actually Robert it looks like we're
about ready to get underway with a round
number 17 the penultimate round of
entire event and once we have the PGN
files coming our way we'll be taking a
look at two of the top players in this
entire event Muhammad I mean a douche
taking on Kenny Sullivan and this is
going to be a key game for Kenny
Solomon's fight to stay in third and to
clinch third can I show you a blooper do
we have time for a blooper before we go
on to the yeah it quick so yes sure
let's begin yet so I just wanted to show
you in this position David Silva Arthur
say Guan II where is this from this is
from round 25 but I don't know how you
split that into like the Blitz games
it's just 25 overall and we had an
Italian opening where black actually
managed to neutralize White's initiative
pretty well I mean we see that there's
some double like some really weird pawn
structure on the kingside where both
sides have doubled pawns on the same
file this is just like a cluster of
pawns but they should balance out so I
would say that the hard part is over and
maybe a lesson to be learned from the
Amin game is that when the hard part is
over that's when you let your guard down
and way that's easiest to make a mistake
so in this position white played 95 and
black figured okay I have everything
protected I've done a pretty good job in
the opening I'll just double up on the
e-file
and you know neutralize the e-file and
all of a sudden after rookie seven boom
96 and you have to resign so it just
goes to show you you know you can never
get too cocky in chess so really too bad
for sig Hwanhee who had played the
opening flawlessly and blundered the
game away in one move now do we have the
game starting Chrome yeah it looks e6 we
do have boards now so we said we wanted
to look at the game between a douche and
Salomon right well it's actually solid
solid laying white against fiducia
game too
tournament who's gonna get third place
right
I think if Solomon wins this game he
clinches third all right yes he does so
well
so here's round 17 here we go so we have
a typical position of the Kings Indian
defense however I quite like White's
position here do you know why why is
that well there's a rule that I like to
follow whenever I'm playing with white
against the Kings Indian and that is if
I close the center
I should not Castle kingside and if I
Castle kingside I should not close the
center because let's say black makes a
random and I Castle here this is gonna
give black a free hand in starting his
King side attack with moves like f5 at
for g5 and g4 so as long as my king is
not castled on the Kings side black is
not going to have a clear target because
this King is going to be pretty safe in
the center and in fact if it's gonna
castle anywhere it's gonna go to the
Queen side so we see that Solomon really
understanding this position plays his
pawn to h4 showing he has no intention
of castling kingside in fact you might
even launch a King side attack of his
own here we see a live shot of the
players actually thanks to Babatunde
Hogan sue Owen I'm sick of the head of
Africa chess media you can check them
out at African chess Mediacom their
coverage of this event is superb and it
was really the epicenter of coverage for
this rapid in blitz uh-huh excellent so
going back to this position we see that
most importantly White has not committed
his king but secondly White has also
established his ideal peace development
so this is a nice pattern of development
to take note of in the King's Indian
this is where White's pieces want to go
because white
if black doesn't do anything is simply
going to play B 3 a 3 B 4 and C 5 and
start playing on the queenside and push
blacks pieces back in the process so
this is a delicate position for black
let's see black just played to move pawn
to h5 so clearly he was a little bit
worried about white playing h5 and
opening up the age problem now I don't
know if you remember yesterday our
interview with Kenny Solomon remember I
do remember I asked him ok so you got
another game coming with a douche how
are you gonna go about that game and he
says I'm not tackled and he doesn't like
that that's what I'm gonna do and I
think that's what he's doing here I mean
look at this font age for maybe a move
he wouldn't play against a different
opponent or in a different situation but
he's sort of an a force win scenario and
could we call this a bit of a grudge
match I mean they played twice already
and Solomon was lost in both games so
I'm sure that huh douche is a little bit
you know frustrated did it Kenny won
both of those games were both draws they
both draws yeah so in both of those
games Kenny got a pretty bad position
out of the opening so here it looks like
it's quite the opposite I mean I would
be very happy if I had this position
with what I would probably continue with
a move like Queen c2 B 3 a 3 and sort of
be on standby if I want to push before I
might go over it b1 and then before
because you have to be mindful that it's
not that easy to open up the 8d a file
but also we need to be a little bit
careful if we play a move like a 3
because black blacks natural response is
to go a 4 and fix the Queen side so now
it's not going to be easy for us to play
before and sometimes but can even
sacrifice this pawn and get the bishop
pair and look at these dark squares
I'm not saying it's full compensation
maybe this needs to be prepared a little
bit but it's definitely something that
black should keep in mind so let's see
if we have some more moves here I think
we do so the game way h5 Queen c2 f5 e
takes f5 and he takes f5 an interesting
move normally you don't want to make
this move because you allow G takes and
this gives black mobile pause in the
center but here we might be looking at
an exception because now that the h5
pawn is unprotected we can take it and
this just wins a pawn now I'm sure black
is probably analyzing this position
thinking maybe it's worth the pawn if I
just go Knight f6 and then start pushing
my pawns but probably not because your
King is too exposed so in the game black
played Bishop takes f5 white goes Knight
d4 now notice why I had previously said
that this is such a nice development
develop a developing pattern of minor
pieces for white because you're ready to
really seize control over the ephah or
outpost now this knight on e4 is looking
great we can always strengthen it it
moves like Bishop f3 or f3 but it's
clear we have to keep this knight on e4
because we can never allow black to play
E for and activate this Bishop that is a
big no-no in the Kings ending so for
example after a move like Knight f6 we
can do anything except Knight takes f6
this would be a serious mistake write
something like Knight takes Bishop takes
you have to defend h4 and now I can go
oh wait wondering my queen so we got to
do something about this so maybe Queen
d2 and now you could take on h4 we could
play something like e for maybe as well
the point is black has tremendous
activity nightmare position for white so
we need to keep this knight on e4 let's
see what happened in the game
oh we have quite a few moves
so after 94 night takes takes Knight f6
so black trying to destabilize this
night Bishop d3 tanks takes Queen d7 and
a 4 a 4 usually not the move that I want
to make because now if black plays
something like b6 how is white going to
crack this Queen side open I'm guessing
that white might have been concerned
with a possible b5 but this isn't
something that should bother us I mean
we could probably go something like
Queen d3 maybe something like g3 as well
to defend this pawn now that there's no
F pawn to store mus with we could
actually even consider castle because if
something like b5 we'll just go pawn
takes and it's only going to expose the
backward pawn on c7 so a for committing
your pawn structure too soon I think
sohe douche played King h7 maybe trying
to activate this Bishop through h6
oh and we had the Meuse b6 + f3 included
as well so yeah I think that already
blacks position is starting to look
pretty decent right and I mean hadoo she
has to be confident its position he's
taking significant amounts of time to
look away from the board I suppose he's
looking at the screen with the other
games in progress as well okay yeah here
I think that black can just play very
easy moves I mean you can throw in the
move Bishop h6 I don't think this is a
good trait for white but at the same
time this Bishop on g7 seems like what
you would call a bad Bishop because we
have a lot of pawns on dark squares
however if I was white let's say if I
played a move like castles after Bishop
h6 if I don't trade these bishops if I
go Bishop f2l if this bishop isn't bad
at all I mean because these pause on
dark squares are in no way interfering
with the action of the bishop on h6 so
it's important not to be dogmatic with
these principles you know okay we have
pause on dark squares but as long as
they don't really mess with our Bishop
you couldn't we shouldn't say that this
Bishop is bad so we had some craziness
happen here after King age 7 Solomon
figures okay black is getting a grip on
this position I'd better start something
soon so g4 h g4 f g4 Bishop takes g4 and
h5 and look at this a nice tactical shot
by Salomon this is exactly the kind of
game he was hoping for before the start
of the round
he's completely opened up the Kings side
now this King on HS Evan doesn't look so
smart and perhaps H thinks g6 is coming
or maybe Bishop takes followed by h6 but
I would really want to open up the H
fall for this rook so the trick here is
that you can't play Bishop takes h5
because of rook takes or we could even
play Bishop takes as well because the
King will have to move and then maybe we
can take with the bishop and that would
clear the diagonal for the Queen so I
think
black in a bit of trouble here after h5
game when king g 8 hg 6 Brooke f3 Bishop
takes oh he gave up the exchange hoping
to relieve some of the attack but now
tweenage to queen g4 Shaq and King f8
now I don't know if I can go rook F 1
this would be very tempting this what
happened in the game rook F 1 yeah II
for Bishop d4 Queen g3 King Ditu Queen G
to Brooke f to mean g5 check and now
King c2 so the bishop on d4 is taboo
because you're always getting made it on
f7 and I'm threatening Queen takes g7 so
what are you gonna do here Queen h6 only
move to protect the bishop let's take a
look at the board close-up here yeah
because both players have less than 10
seconds left and they're just working
with a three-second delay here so what's
he gonna do man Salomon just okay so
this is we're gonna get the position
Bishop b4 now Queen h6 check check and
queen age six this is what what's going
to happen yep
so he's threatening taken g17 hsx only
move and he defended against me
Solomon got like 20 seconds on the clock
he's got to keep the Queens on the board
akela the Queen trade that's gonna make
blacks life a lot easier
so maybe take on g7 okay rook h1 wait
what about the bishop on before isn't it
hanging bishop takes
did he just blunder the bishop I think
he did oh man oh my goodness what a
blunder by wife now black is just up at
peace and there's no more checkmate this
bishop this dark square Bishop defends
everything I think this game is over
like just brings the King out
oh he's not up at peace because he gave
up in exchange before so he has two
bishops for a rook this is still a big
advantage now the pawn in g6 is gonna
fall yeah yeah Salomon still has an
advantage here right no I mean I think
Solomon's just busted the two bishops
and look at this upon it's running no
chance here all he's got to do is get
that Bishop to h4 and okay so he has to
give up the rook for the pawn and Bishop
well from from my our experience when
the video freezes up that's when the
game is over yeah and besides we see
that eventually uh that's you
after the video cut off it wasn't too
long for Solomon to resign that game I
mean that's too bad because he had a
winning position and a great attack I
thought that here after Queen age six he
could simply take on g7 and after Queen
takes try to keep the Queens on the
board or maybe it's not so easy I don't
know I was I was saying okay let me just
get my queen out of here
I mean h4 and even if you do take on g6
this is just gonna open up some some
lines for my for my rooks I can't go
rook f1 yet because of III maybe okay I
can just get my rook out of here yeah I
think King safety and the extra exchange
should give away a winning position
do we have any other games going on or
as well and over yes we have three games
still going on it looks like my goodness
Elodie Nani it is losing to David Silva
mate is imminent if it already hasn't
happened that has led Nani is live
fourth place
so okay this is so actually important
for Kenny Solomon as well yeah I mean
Solomon lost that game that would have
if he had won it would have clinched
them third place and now Ellen Ani
catching up so I think he's like a half
point behind is that right I think it is
so right now yes I mean what happened in
this L at Nani game no no I'm sorry he's
a he's a whole point behind a full point
behind so if Solomon loses again again
and Ellen Ani wins he catches up exactly
and we have David Silva in the mix now
with 19 points yeah so so we have
Solomon at 19 1/2 Silva 19
Ellen 1980s Oh so Solomon can actually
lose third place not even tie for it
absolutely okay so maybe he's feeling
the heat okay we do have one game left
in action unless there is a result we
don't know about we're go tomorrow
versus Bell hood yeah you're right so
this is the last game but this was now
it's drawn okay yeah usually Queen and
Knight is a little bit better than Queen
and Bishop but if it's only Queen at
night against only Queen and Bishop it's
kind of a tough to really make anything
out of it but it seems like Rocco no
mahara was pushing it at one point he
had two extra pawns but weak pawns and
very weak control over dark squares yeah
this should be the drum especially with
your King so exposed and vulnerable to
Bishop checks yeah no problem
for black to hold this game what other
games do we have here
how did Bossin Amin do yeah let's take a
look we do have 13 minutes until our
final round of the tournament is
underway let's take a look at this game
so before c5 Knight f3 d6 so there we go
we have that Kings Indian attack
trademark a Bostonian now he goes for c3
d4 is that of your typical d3 Knight bTW
- well never mind you doubled back and
there we go
so 92 Bishop e6 93 p6 Bishop b2
we're c8 b5 Bishop takes b3 so this is a
common idea when you're trying to
prepare d4 you want to loosen your
opponent's control over the center so
you want it expand on the Queen side
drive this night away from the center
maybe if Knight B 8 now the move d4 is
going to make some more sense because
black can't control
d4 as easily with a knight on b8
maybe something like tank stakes I'm not
so sure my idea was that if you take I
can go Knight takes and I even have a c6
outpost for my knight but maybe you can
use some tactics here because my minor
pieces look very awkward right I mean if
I go Knight d2 you go c3 and you fork me
and if I go Knight c1 you'd actually
trap my bishop so the idea is right the
execution maybe not so much so perhaps I
need to prepare d4 a little bit maybe I
can get my night out of b3 and then go
for D form let's see what happened in
the game black played Bishop takes b3
which I think what should be pretty
happy to see I mean whenever your
opponent gives you a bishop for a knight
it doesn't mess up your pawn structures
doesn't really create any structural
problems for you then you should take
that as a win so now after Queen c2 we
don't even need to play d4 because we've
already achieved a strategic advantage
so now after C for D for Queen d7 a4
this just looks like a better position
for white rook c5 Bishop a3 rook c7 look
at this and a couple of moves blacks
position has completely imploded I mean
he lost the bishop pair he took on a
backward pawn on d6 centralized the
white knight now rook a d1 is coming and
you're gonna have a really hard time
protecting d6 so 9 p 7f 4
Knights e5 f5 takes takes and this is
not looking good for black so Fisher
five six Bishop c1 the King h7h form
preparing something like Queen d2 and
taking away the g5 square for the bishop
so h4 perhaps threatening Queen d2 rook
g8 there you go Queen d2 takes takes
rook takes g3 D takes e5 and I think
game is pretty much over white still has
an attack and he has an extra piece and
he still has the bishop pair and I would
dare say even still has a better pawn
structure or whatever pause Black has
left right
they all start getting chopped off now
Queen c7 rook D 195 takes takes takes
yeah I mean this game went out a few
more moves but when you're down what is
it to pieces against Boston I mean you
better have checkmate in one move
otherwise I think he's just gonna rip
you to pieces right well you know it's
blitz anything it is bullets yeah who
knows how much time boss no I mean had
at this point let's see what other game
we had so we already saw the Solomon
against a douche game what I'd like to
do while you're taking a look at that is
glance at the updated standings because
you know the leaderboard hasn't changed
much but just a little bit is we just
have got one game left one point for
every player that could possibly be
earned in this tournament and so a lot
of a lot of these standings are actually
set in stone right now with one and two
solidified but now the battle is up for
that third place pot mm-hmm what you're
saying and a half points so mean so do
we have the pairings for the last round
because we have like this Ellen on e
Silva Solomon bottleneck for third place
okay yeah yeah if we could just look at
those pairings I'm gonna pull up a game
in the meantime you've raised a good
point because if any of those guys are
playing each other it's going to be a
pretty exciting final round mm-hmm all
right here are the pairings for blitz
round 18 the final round of the cote
d'ivoire rapid in blitz itself David
Silva vs Andrew que onda Arthur say Guan
Yi versus Kenny Solomon Muhammad a
douche versus fever KO tomorrow
slim Valhalla vs. bossom Ameen and Ola
da boo adieu versus ill I mean okay well
I don't know that we're getting what we
wished for well we're not getting any
direct matchups between the players
involved and the fight for a third place
so it's actually gonna depend
everybody's gonna depend on themselves
right so if Solomon pulls off the win
against sequani then there's nothing
really but silver or pellet none you can
do right right he's a half point above
his nearest competitor it's in Solomon's
hands but he has the black pieces but
his blitz anything can happen
yeah and you know Ellen Ani has black
against Ola Doppler do but I do not
having a great tournament so maybe the
fact that he's having black is gonna
balance the fact that he's playing a
player that's not doing so well in the
event I mean we've seen a lot of do
faltering in this thing but it's you
have to remember also that say Guan Yi
is only a half point higher up than they
do in this event so we're looking at the
the players with the black pieces in
these events with players with the white
pieces that haven't been performing so
well well in this round that just ended
there was a big win because David Silva
meet L at nani with black and that's
what catapulted him to the fight for
third place because now after beating L
at nani he passed ellen any
understanding indeed and is within
striking distance of solomon so let's
see how he managed to pull off that win
so it was a round 26 L is not a white
David silver black so we have eight
kings Indian and these openings are so
important when you're playing rapid and
blitz because you know that at least the
first six or seven moves you're gonna be
able to blitz them out and not have to
think so you're going to avoid getting
into time trouble soon in the game and
also you're gonna have a sort of
practical advantage and knowing where
your pawns go where your pieces go
so being able to fall back on some
system rather than some forced variation
you know theoretically challenging
variation where you have to play very
accurately has a lot more value in these
time controls than for example say
playing some mainline Sicilian night or
for example where you might have to take
a minute or two just to remember the
theory so here you don't really need to
remember anything you just figure okay
get my pieces out identify what the
strong squares are and get a piece to
that square so I think that's what black
is doing here is trying to go ninety six
ninety four so white definitely on to
Black's idea was to control d4 with c3
and maybe get his own Knight to c4 in d6
so 96 93 94 night see for the night does
get to d6 but let's not forget d6 is not
an outpost so we'll see how stable this
night actually is I would have prevented
the knight from getting to d4 sooner
when it move like c3 now rook a c1
trying to get this Knight out of here
and is this a blunder is 92 mm-hmm I
think that's what happened in this game
yeah 92 takes takes Bishop f1 Queen f3
okay the Queen looks a little bit
unstable that is a dog in the background
in case her viewers are wondering yeah
it's a large dog in the next room it's a
really nice dog - I was petting it
yesterday
yeah Bishop g2 what's it called
spirit Fox thunder fox ffox are all
acceptable Wow so definitely foxy your
dog yes okay so Queen area right now
what it's very upset right now
yeah still parking so Queen f6 so the
Queen made it out I think that white
just wondered this exchange okay he'll
get a pawn but this is a position that's
not particularly bad for the rooks
because we see that there are at least
two good files to use for the rooks
and this night okay it's gonna get to c5
it might give a little bit of
compensation to white so after night c5
Bishop e7 Knight b3 rook d7 takes takes
the knight comes back to c5 all right
the knight looks beautiful on c5 but I
mean life is gonna go rook the 8th maybe
bring the King up a little bit if white
is able to create an outside pasture
with moves like C 3 and B 4 and trade
his C pawn for blacks a pawn maybe we're
in business but that's not going to be
easy with so many works on the board
especially if the rooks get to the 2nd
rank so 93 f6 Bishop f1 rook d4 b3 King
f7 f3 rook e d7 King F to work c7 night
c5 King D 6 yeah and c5 is really
White's only jewel in the position so if
we can take this away from white the
position is probably going to collapse
so black is preparing to go King d6 and
seize control over the c5 square ideally
I think this King would want to be on b6
so it won't block the D file so after
king b6 the night will drop back and
then as black I would try I would try to
maneuver my King to be 6 so that the
King won't be in the way of the roots
because the open file is going to be
where we want to place our roof so after
h5 986 rook c8 95 white basically forced
to sit and wait and then what do you
think of this move after g4 what would
you play is black would you take on g4
or would you go h4
we should always weigh the pros and cons
I would think I mean at first glance I
would take ya because you figure okay I
have rooks therefore I can use the open
file much easier than my opponent this
is the first thing that I would evaluate
in this position it would be all I take
and rook h8 and activate my other rook
perfect but also there's something to be
said about the move played in the game
h4 because this gives black what's known
in chess as proximity promotion in any
endgame we have black is going to have a
nice pawn on h4 so that if anything ever
happens to the pawn on h3 this pawn is
as good as a queen so let's see what
happened bishop a6 rook b8 Bishop d3 we
got some extensive maneuvering here so
I'm just gonna jump to the next critical
moment in the game where black already
maneuvered the King to b6 and drove the
white knight back to d3 and after Bishop
a 692 takes takes King a six-night b2
rook d4 black actually found it kind of
difficult to really make progress so it
turns out that maybe h6g for rook h2 it
would have been the best so let's see
how black finally won this game he had
to risk quite a bit on the Queen side in
order to chop down this h3 pawn and get
a queen so now after rook d2 we actually
see some themes being combined right
trying to take h3 but now uh-oh King's
safety b7 King c7 be a white gave a few
checks but now had to do something to
avoid checkmate and after takes King out
three well he resigned didn't even wait
for checkmate in one minute so kind of a
thriller the 20 year old junior player
from Angola David Silva is in contention
for third place Torres and speaking of
the contention for third place our final
round is underway at chess 24 comm join
us for the live game game in five three
second delay don't delay get
there now if you're not there already
but I think we should look what do you
think Kenny Solomon's game since it's
all in his hands should we look at that
or should we look at another so we have
Silva against Kai own day we have sigani
against Salomon I think you're right I
mean because if this game is won by
Salomon that's it it don't matter what
Silva or Ellen I do so let's see what we
have here
there's a nice live shot of the players
yep so we have a scotch opening we're
generally what happens is black will get
speedy development get all his pieces in
play but you will have a worst pawn
structure so black is going to be in a
race against time to make his
development count before white finishes
moves like Bishop b2 g3 Bishop g2 Castle
King side and centralizes is rooks if
black is sorry if black allows white to
do all this he's going to have a bad
position because his pawn structure is
worse Bishop on a6 it's biting into a
very strong pawn chain a 2 B 3 C 4 let's
see how a black played black castle so
clearly getting his king out of the
center before he tries to open up the
position some possible moves for white
I mean developing this King side ain't
going to be easy because it's gonna take
you a lot of time you're gonna have to
go either g3 Bishop g2 or something like
Queenie for Bishop e2 or Bishop d3 but
in either case black is gonna try to
chip away your key 5 pawn which is
either d6 or f6 so let's see
it still hasn't played I mean very
strange that's iguana taking you so much
time in the opening considering this is
a blitz game he's already down to three
minutes and it's only moved ten so there
is a technique in blitz that I like to
use quite a bit what is that I
sacrificed my position for time so I'll
make moves quickly maybe not the best
news but at least I won't fall behind on
the clock
I played usually the opposite of that
but it really depends on if there's an
increment and just make good news all
the time I was playing this guy no no no
how many better moves on my opponent
hopefully but I was playing this guy
outside the other night and he would
just blitzing through the opening just
playing something round yeah well the
thing is you got to think of the clock
as another piece you know so you can't
just focus on your position and be like
okay I'll I'll think a lot and just have
a good position well the clock is part
of your position so if you're down two
minutes on move ten you gotta be it's
going to be like being down a pond or a
couple pots so like a punt upon a minute
is that one a minute I don't know I mean
we're in uncharted territory right now
we're really writing the rulebook on how
important the clock is I guess it also
might depend on the kind of position but
upon a minute I think might be a little
harsh maybe like give you like to pause
for me know two minutes for a pause
sure okay all right going over to minute
let's make a deal so white played
Queenie four so he decided against the
g3 idea and is simply going for Bishop
e2 and castles now this Queen could be a
target on e4 but I'm guessing that if d5
or d6 right away where you might still
be able to go pawn takes because this
Queen is protected but I'm wondering
after takes takes rook e8 what's next
because now f5 is coming
so after Queenie for how is black good
and perceived maybe after d5 I can just
take on d5 and you take on f1 and now I
can just get my King out of this ePHI so
that after you go C takes okay I just
moved my queen maybe I do check and then
I try to go g3 King g2 and finish my
development and I still have a better
pawn structure so we see that in the
game
Solomon played rook e8 so putting
pressure on the e5 pawn right away and
now definitely pinning this pawn for
example if you go f4 I can definitely
play d5 or d6 because if you go e d now
the queen is not protected and actually
I could even try to win your Queen right
away with a move like Queen b8 instead
of winning your knight so after rook e8
white is gonna have to be very very
careful
he did play up for so did we go d6 do we
go defy do we maybe try to jab away at
the f4 pawn black played f6 so again we
can't take so it seems like we're going
to lose a pawn what do we do because if
we go something like Bishop e2 after F
takes
I mean we can't just keep the e-file
closed with that 5 because D 5 is coming
and if takes you take on e 2 and if King
takes e 2 I don't know I'm just really
scared about having this King here
remember we gave up this pawn on d5 but
we already want to pawn on e5 as well so
material is even but White's King safety
seems a lot worse than blacks so let's
see what happened in the game white
played Bishop b2 so his idea must be
that against F takes just wants to get
this King out of here and if you go e
takes f4 I'm guessing just Queen takes
and is white gonna have enough
compensation here I mean what happens if
I just trade Queens after takes and rook
takes I'm still a little bit behind in
development after Bishop d3 but I think
I could just bring this Bishop out
somehow okay Knight
oh maybe it's not so easy right because
White's bishops are putting a lot of
pressure on blacks King side so if I
played a normal developing move like
Bishop before for example can white do
something like 94 or maybe 92 so I don't
block this Bishop white might have a
little bit of compensation because his
bishops are very active and black still
hasn't brought the bishops on a6 and the
night on b6 into the game so this is
what happened Bishop b2 F takes e5
Castle queenside still I think this is a
good approach by Solomon because he is a
forced win situation as black and one of
the best ways to go about those delicate
times when you're forced to win is black
is to choose a line where you kind of go
pawn grabbing not too many pawns just
one pawn and then you know that the game
is gonna be completely imbalanced you're
either gonna win or you're gonna lose
bet draw is not the most likely result
and at the same time you're not come
destroying your position right I mean
Black has a decent pawn structure maybe
his pieces on a six and B six aren't
great but he should be able to fix this
eventually so we see that he takes f4
Queen takes f4 happened where is the f8
bishop gonna go I mean are we gonna
trade Queens on e3 first and then worry
about development or can we get away
with something like g5 and Bishop g7
keep the Queens on the board but finish
developing the Kings I know he went for
the Queen trade Queen e3 he has to take
rook cakes and it's an endgame but it's
gonna be a fun end game because both
players have less than a minute so we
don't know what's gonna happen here
after rook takes c3 Bishop d3 seems to
make a lot of sense putting pressure on
this King side and making blacks
development difficult yep
Bishop d3
and it seems like white is just gonna go
something like 92 or 94 actually like 94
so that I can go 95 eventually and maybe
9 f7 and Bishop takes h7l when in
exchange if I can do that so black needs
to be very very careful here can he go
something like c5 and Bishop b7 maybe
although that does neglect your King
side development but at least it brings
your Queen side pieces into the game you
could also try to do something like
Bishop e7 followed by Bishop f6 yep
that's what he's going for
so this is gonna try to neutralize the
bishop on b2 so if you could just have
enough time to go Bishop f6 so I think
you should definitely go 94 now because
you're hitting g7 and you're stopping
Bishop f6 94 is a multi-purpose move yep
94 d5 so this was the idea now you're
not going to be able to keep your knight
on e4 and Bishop f6 is coming so
black finishes his development but after
Bishop f6 Bishop tanks she takes that
King site pawn structure doesn't look so
great either
Robert big news no good Silva has won
his game that means that Kenny Solomon
has to win this game - oh wow third okay
otherwise do you think he knows there's
really no way of telling I mean there
seems very focused in the game I don't
think he's there are any close quarters
there in that hotel room but look at
density King b7 Bishop c100 did he just
blunder the exchange rook on e3 is
hanging you can't move it but he's
getting a lot of pawns Bishop takes oh
yeah I don't know white is up in
exchange but Black has three pawns for
it although it's true that those pawns
are some ugly Queen site pause we have
doubled isolated pawns on c7 and c6 and
an isolated pawn on a7 so is the bishop
pair and the clones gonna be enough and
now we have a centralized knight on d5
outpost I think black should have very
decent chances here look at this we have
sturdy pieces on d5 and f6
the White King is a little bit exposed
maybe Bishop
you can't go Bishop c4 because the rook
on g4 just takes it so h5 Solomon trying
to destabilize this rook on G forces so
that he can bring his bishop into the
game so Brooke a4 Bishop b5 maybe now
the a pawn starts rolling
Oh saman missed Knight c3 fork could
afford the white king and roll man yeah
so an oversight by both players
that's why Solomon was shaking his head
can you go Knight c3 no yeah he's pinned
what's the time
can you see the times yeah three seconds
for seg wanye okay now now they are
using a Bronstein delay which means that
it appears like it's an increment but
it's not they're just getting a
three-second delay they don't use it all
they're not getting it back
Soloman getting his exchange back and
sig why are you playing it really cool I
mean when I have three seconds I don't
look that cool
Salomon at ten seconds yeah - Shak king
b3 is there mate summer oh oh and white
resigns so what would have happened
after King takes that final position oh
now look at this this we're now looking
at the game between Josh and code Omaha
row
oh he resigned because now if King takes
c3 you're Brooke is hanging on b1 ok
couldn't see that from the angle in the
video let's let's get a close-up of this
particular matchup here so what do we
have here is Muhammad have you shivers
is fever ko tomorrow okay let's see
what's going on here and I mean remember
hadoo she's a for sure second place so
you guys made up there you go checkmate
that didn't last long
no at least we got to see it yeah how
about that so so are all the games over
now no oh my goodness my bottom is still
playing yes we're looking at and it'll
you know gia in bossom all right we've
got but we've got image of this oh look
at these losing weight right awesome oh
no no draw this draw doctor I don't know
I go home and so you locked up what was
happening here in this final position
after Bishop takes c3 black didn't go
rook takes d3 I don't know what's
happening here
I guess he saw a ghost I mean after rook
takes d3 maybe he got scared any
thoughts that after g7 rook the eight
rook d7 was a problem but here you have
a nice little tactic rook takes d7 and
if
she ate Queen Oh root g7 and now it's
black that's winning
so maybe Bosma me missed that variation
and played Bishop h6 and this to me it
looks like a winning position for white
I mean can't we just go rook f7 or after
Bishop b4 he offered a draw that seems
strange
I mean rook f7 King e6 Bishop c4 driving
your King as far as possible from this
g6 pawn and now I mean I can just go
rotate 7 g7 and g8
are you sure that the draw was offered
well it was a draw I mean I see it's a
draw but sometimes sometimes there's
relay errors it's really tough to tell
at this moment all right
well we'll check up on it but this is
the final position and it says draw and
the video cut out so I don't know I
guess we'll assume it's a draw in the
interim it would have been an
interesting way to finish the tournament
for slim Belko dia who had a bad start
in the rapid lick but then quickly made
up for it in the blitz portion not
enough I mean I think at one point he
lost eight games in a row yes when you
lose eight games in a row you know it's
not gonna be a good day at the office
and they they were valuable games they
were the rather rated games so 0 out of
16 at one point that sounds like
something I would do like yeah I would
lose all the important games and then
just went all that so we'll be talking
to our our top placers here in just a
bit but let's let's take a glance at
some games from this round that we
didn't really get to see
oh by the way Ellen 91 as well oh you
had mentioned that before
now you said Silva won but L at 91 - so
all our main guys won so it's a good
thing that Solomon won that game because
otherwise they would have overtaken him
right interesting
so the final standings now we're
probably gonna be bossom amin mohammed
huh douche solomon silva and ella Donny
look it I guessed it total shot in the
dark well you got it right here we are I
mean this is the final standings for
this tournament the best we can tell and
and I have to say something about these
players that maybe not a lot of people
know this tournament when it was
organized and these players were given
invitations all of them quite
enthusiastically accepted and they
traveled to a beach on the camp one of
the capitals of Ivory Coast and to
compete in this rapid and blitz event so
they're all to be commended quite
immensely but here we have our top
placers first of all in fifth place from
Morocco in fact he's Morocco's highest
rated international master mo Cleese
al-adnani and with 19 and a half points
he will go home with $1,000 in fourth
place international master David Silva
from Angola the triple African junior
champion just 20 years old he leaves
with fourth out - pardon me $2,000 in
third place
grand master from South Africa Kenny
Solomon with 20 and a half points he
will leave with 3 grand and in second
place our runner-up and dare I say the
champion of the normal human field in a
supposedly superhuman field Grandmaster
Muhammad Amin kaduche from Algiers
Algeria one of three grandmasters from
that country he came to Ivory Coast and
showed he was the real deal 24 points
grand total and he leaves with $4,000
and of course our champion of the 2018
Cote d'Ivoire rapid and Blitzen
a tional as we expected from egypt
grandmaster bossom amin 29 incredible 29
points he leaves with the grand prize
$5,000
the reigning African champion his title
not on the line of this event but he
proved why he is the African champion
and well there just wasn't a competition
for a first place it is good
absolutely so we're gonna get our
interviews on the phone here in just a
moment so it was there a game you wanted
to take yeah while you do that I just I
was curious to see how Ella Donnie won
his game against Ole adop would do
because he was definitely under some
pressure to win and see if he could
actually sneak into third place now as
we know both Solomon and Silva won but
had they not had they lost he would have
gotten a third place with this last
round win over International Master from
Nigeria Paula Dawa doom so we see a sort
of Slav pawn structure where blankets
the bishop pair but he gets this nasty
little weakness this backward pawn oc6
now it has been my experience that in
blitz these little weaknesses don't tend
to pay off as much as they do in
classical chess because you really need
time to work on a square and usually you
know your opponent will get some kind of
compensation and here I'm thinking black
is going to play something like H 5 H 4
or F 5 F 4 is going to start attacking
me and I just try to get my Knights on a
nice outpost I'm gonna get checkmated
and that is always unpleasant so here we
see that black did go for the f5
a4 idea now actually pawn to f3 so this
already looks like something's going
wrong for white because all your pieces
are stuck on the Queen Sun you're
getting attacked on the King side again
King safety should be your number one
priority
and now look at this bishop it looked
terrible a few moons ago on a 8 now it's
coming to f3 White's act upon and this
position is getting out of control for
white we have wide open position bishop
pair king safety problems I think this
game is pretty much over
so or do we have someone on the line
ready for an interview yes for the first
time is it are good for one moment you
lost the connection there for just a
moment but we're gonna have him our
runner-up Mohammed Khan douche one
moment here this is a turn off my camera
all right
grandmaster from algeria mohammad a
douche welcome to the show for the very
first time sir it's great to have you i
know that we have a translator in the
house but we had to talk to the
runner-up of this event what how would
you comment on this tournament in
general players have super grand master
Besim
I mean in the Solomons and the others
have 24 rating they are strong players
where does this tournament ranked in
importance to other rapid and blintz
events that you have played in the past
this is the I played the first song
tournament like this
blitz and rapid in Africa whenever play
is a tsunami in Africa like this who
play the best player in each country
from Asia from Tunisia from Morocco this
is very strong to a moment yeah
hello Mohammed this is Grand Master
Robert on gaskey we've been following
your games very exciting I'd like to
congratulate you on your second place
and ask you which leg of the tournament
did you think was best for you the rapid
or the blitz seems I think I played the
one in rapid yesterday I played any bed
first day of blitz
I was out but today I played like
Deadwood
some some things and good athletes did
you notice that maybe in this last day
the players were feeling tired or were
you tired as well because no these were
an incredible amount I was undecided
because we might now stop it online
announcer blitz I think I was I was
tired of the city and it's interesting I
was following the games that you played
against Kenny Solomon and in the first
two games you had winning positions and
they were drawn and in the last games it
seemed like you were losing and you
ended up winning so it seems like things
never end up the way you think
yes I guess someone in the last game was
lost in this position but the replay
this is risky yeah he must yes he must
one yeah never give up so I think that
was a very important game as well
because you were both fighting for
second place and after you won that game
it was uh it was all pretty much decided
so again congratulations and I guess now
it's kind time to rest go home and relax
you Thank You Addison okay thank you all
right thank you
Mohammed huh do Sh second place he is
the runner-up to the the champion who we
will talk to in just a moment awesome
Amin
but yeah the 2018 cote d'ivoire rapid
and blitz i think that this has been
just a fun tournament I think that it
has exposed African chess which you
don't really get to see a lot mm-hmm
hopefully we can have more of these
events in the future but right now we
have a man on the line who is no
stranger to this show but there's a
reason we've talked to him for about
well this is the third time but now we
can say officially he is the champion of
the 2018 coach of our rapid and blitz
grandmaster dr. bossom amin from egypt
bossom congratulations you clinched it
in blitz round 12 but we kind of knew
there was a foregone conclusion give us
your thoughts after a final day of play
well thank you yeah it was a very tough
event and quite long yeah I think I got
quite today also has been organized the
first time and I really hope you know it
could happen again and there's we'll get
used to it you know
I'm sure it's time you know it will get
stronger and stronger and yeah it will
help you compare to improve your level
of course explain the importance of
having a tournament complete with a
broadcast and this kind of exposure and
prize fund on the African continent why
is it so important okay for most of
African players they don't play strong
tournaments I mean these players go to
get but that's it because we don't have
an African individuals I mean basically
two tournaments if it will be two years
you know so to have opportunity to play
against strong players or another
grandmasters so it's very important for
us and okay such level of organization
and broadcasting is bringing all media
attention in Africa so it's really big
I possum this is Robert hyung Gasca
congratulations on your title I just had
a couple of technical questions I mean
we were following your last round game
that ended in a drought and it seemed
like you were in a little bit of trouble
and that final position after Bishop
before word did he offer a draw or what
happened there no I've seen I think
there is a mistake in front because he
didn't have the g6 poon oh okay well
that's makes a difference so never mind
was taken okay that explains a lot so it
was a draw it was just there's no g6
pawn okay yeah okay alright we were
analyzing that the wrong position but
also it was a day full of emotions for
you you also lost your first and only
game of the tournament so it just goes
to to prove what you were saying she
lost oh you lost to today wait wait a
minute
never mind I just okay I hadn't seen the
mokele as one yet yeah well it just goes
to show what you were saying earlier in
the tournament that these players are
very strong and underrated and exactly
and of course I mean in such a long
event where you know you start feeling
tired after the first 30 games you know
yeah of course
all right so I'll let you I'll let you
go and enjoy your result and rest you
know get some rest and relax thanks a
lot and thanks for you two for a great
cover Capricciosa five days ago I really
enjoyed watching it up nights and you
did great job all right thank you very
much anymore so place thank you sir all
right that's Grandmaster dr. bossom Amin
the champion of the 2018 cote d'ivoire
rapid and blitz invitational well this
has been just a spectacular
I really enjoyed it - it's a shame if
anything that we didn't get to see it
clinched it in the last two rounds when
we were on the air maybe we'll have to
start earlier next time huh yeah well I
mean you can't have it all but I think
we we definitely had enough yeah because
we were never lacking for games I mean
how many rounds did we cover 27 rounds
total in this event
27 so don't like more well you had three
three three nine nine
oh no okay yeah 27 I see I see what you
mean yeah yeah
so ton of the games and I'm actually
gonna have to go dig up this other game
that Boston lost I wasn't aware he lost
two games against Elliot Navi yeah yeah
I saw the result that yeah I didn't
really take a look at the game at all
interesting so what's next for now well
I'll tell you what's next for me for the
club for the entire chess world starting
in August we have the grand chest tour
now we've just seen the rapid and blitz
in ivory coast but that was the same
format as the st. Louis rapid and blitz
and for that matter the other rapid and
blitz events of the grand chest or we've
already had two grand chests or events
in Leuven and in Paris and now it rolls
through to st. Louis for back-to-back
huge events world-class top 10 players
we're talking about super grandmasters
the st. Louis rapid and blitz kicks off
with festivities on August 10th
however the wrap the first round begins
on August 11th at 1:00 p.m. Central Time
here in the US and the rapid and blitz
is gonna be just five days long okay
it's three days of rapid chess two days
of blitz games and based on the final
standings
those grand chests or points those also
important grand chests or points are on
the line and right now if you don't
recall Wesley so once again at the top
of the leaderboard of the grand chest or
after Paris and lumen 21 points followed
closely by Hikaru Nakamura with 20 now
while we're on this American train
Fabiana Carolina
he's a full tour member so he's playing
in all the events but he only has four
points he did not do well in Paris has
done he's fundamentally probably out of
the running for making the finals you
know he's probably gonna do really well
because he's gonna have no pressure he's
gonna play at the tournament they go
okay I'll just play my chest and his
chest is good hey he's got the World
Championship coming up yeah he's got a
lot going for him now if we can if we
can just bring that graphic up one more
time I gotta talk about the big event
okay I like how that cube almost like
flew into your face the 2018 Sinquefield
Cup six years in the making
man well we've had such a great time
with the Cup over the years since it
started in 2013 and every year has
produced a unique winner
no one's ever won this thing twice and
that is incredible because we've had a
lot of repeat customers I mean this era
of chess is super strong it begins it
goes from August 17th through to the
28th round one is August 18th now the
big story coming out of this Sinquefield
Cup this year is the wild card joining
the nine regular participants of the
grand chess or in the cup this year will
be none other than the world chess
champion Magnus Carlsen which means that
in one of those rounds in this classical
event Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Carolina are facing off in a preview of
the World Championship
yeah Magnus is good too yeah a little
bit don't you say yeah so you can follow
the action online starting on August
11th at grande chest org of course also
just 24 calm but if you're in the US hop
on a train get on a plane get here to
st. Louis we're gonna have an autograph
signing before the Sinquefield Cup you
get the autographs from all of these
great champions it's gonna be amazing
you don't want to miss it and then of
course right before it st. Louis rapid
and blitz the same format is this
tournament what a great preview it's
been and I can't wait for the 34th legs
of the grand chest or coming up yeah
it's gonna be exciting definitely the
best in the world best in the world
converge right here in the US you know
well this show and this entire
tournament was produced by some very
fine people we want to thank dr. ESO
esses the Ivorian Chess Federation
president for his help in this of
Babatunde Ogun siku who is the head of
africa chess media he was there holding
the camera at those boards so we could
get those live shots we really want to
thank him the head of Kasparov chess
foundation Africa Graham Jorgenson also
the technical also the director of the
grant chest tour he was a huge part in
this event getting it put on and of
course on Lenalee ami who had those
beautiful photos the portraits of the
players and it was so important to bring
their faces to you so you could see them
they're more than just names and even
though they're on the other side of the
planet we needed to see them so thank
you Alina now in the u.s. our friends in
the other room the world's greatest
production B team
Tammy Hyde is the technical advisor
making sure this stream doesn't drop
doing a great job Isaac Krantz the art
is the graphics man an audio made all
these graphics from scratch Thank You
Isaac
our technical director is Dennis LaRue
pressing the buttons switching the shots
and here at the desk
I've been Simon I'm Marvin gaskey and I
want to thank you Ben for putting up
with me this whole time
thank you very much you've made some
really off-color jokes but I still thank
you yeah and you can go back and watch
on YouTube and check those off-color
jokes out for yourself or not so chest
24 calm a great host for this cote
d'ivoire rapid and blitz invitational
and remember on august 11th the grande
chest tour continues with the st. louis
rapid and blitz and then right after it
the Sinquefield cup the 6th annual event
the classical powerhouse event it's
gonna be a great time so until August
11th we say so long and always check it
might be made from the show-me-state
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you